[Musique]
je suis florence k et je suis une
artiste une musicienne
si ça n'avait pas été de mon père et de
ma mère j'aurais probablement pas été
une musicienne avec autant d influences
différentes éclatées que ce que je suis
aujourd'hui
donc évidemment on parle beaucoup de ma
maman ma mère nathalie choquette ce
prénom une prendre comédienne aussi je
considère que ma mère est ma elle m'a
appris apa jamais me prendre au sérieux
parce que ne se prend pas du tout
sérieux
mon père lui de son côté c'est pas du
tout un musicien classique c'était un
verre creux il m'a enseigné le sens du
rythme le sens de l'improvisation
chez nous c'est un petit peu comme les
familles de circle est aimé par pour le
board est divisée puis même chanté
escabeau faire avec une victoire à la
menthe et pour m'endormir je regarde ma
mère si j'avais 10 ans je jouais ma mère
en spectacle était déguisé en otaries
qui a chanté du bac fessée c'est
complètement space s'est complètement
spécificités mais si génial en même
temps avec ma mère en 2011 on a monté un
spectacle parfait où est ce qu'on a fait
en sorte que nos deux univers se
rencontrent sur scène et c'est là qu'on
j'ai pu constater à quel point au clash
est vraiment dans nos méthodes de
travail et dans notre façon de percevoir
certains aspects de la scène quand il ya
un clash entre les univers de deux
personnes qui s'aiment c'est là qu'il ya
quelque chose de carrément fantastique
qui peut en résulter
mais il faut passer par dessus l'acheter
sauf qu'on le fait le fait non c'est
vraiment que c'est l'amour ça à ça sert
à ça aussi
pour moi la famille c'est quelque chose
de super important c'est ce sont des
racines c'est un ancrage ce qui est le
plus important je pense ce sont les
liens du coeur plutôt que les liens du
sang
[Musique]